I know the least about cyborg and I feel
like we oughta know it's so weird that
everyone keeps saying that because I
grew up on cyborg oh yeah he rode around
on that trashcan yeah electricity is
that Warner Brothers cartoons you know
he's the one who runs around in his
pajamas with the big Elvis hair oh yeah
we all know hello reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey Justice League we
got our tickets for it
yes day six pm November 16th at the
Cinemark in NoHo you can come say hi if
you want we'll probably be running late
so yeah I'll make it two too long
theater we go to the most at this one I
get recognized at the most and by most
let me talk become their mascot it's all
roads and I go there we got some Justice
League TV spots sent over to us boy we
have like seven sent to us but I only
want with the titles of three that's
sounded like oh maybe this is a little
different they're all only 30 seconds
each let's start up with Mira
from Aquaman land okay that's the
technical word heard another one think
it's like Atlanta the comedy doesn't
stop here doesn't
I mean you are
[Music]
there was
[Music]
let's do it
[Music]
didn't really see it much a mirror
fighting paradigm isn't new but not too
[Music]
[Music]
those are very big guns according to
Alfred quite big guns is is stronger
together one coming up
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
Justice League rated pg-13 experience in
IMAX November 17 all right let's go with
the save 1 now save on it
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I really like out there doing with flash
because I feel like it's easy to go well
you know if everyone's so familiar with
the flash on the TV show well let's just
throw them flash me has already been the
flash for a while but he really seems
like kind of the underdog of the heroes
here he's the one who seems like he's
got the most potential yeah he's
spider-man in this scenario dan
mentoring him yeah you know I gotta do
right by the yet by the boss man yeah
save ward okay I probably would react
that way too
oh yeah I feel like philosophy probably
the most relatable one feel like that
scene is probably gonna be even funnier
cuz I've seen that damn joke so many
times yeah yeah I hope the comedy lands
in this I feel like they that that might
be one of the best else yeah this movie
is some of the humor well here's how I'm
feeling about Justice League and I've
been saying it over and over again I
only care truthfully at this point I
just care that it's fun visually
impressive and just really fun that's
all I really care about okay okay I know
other people have different opinions as
you are super entitled to mm-hm any cane
this guy who just expects finally
bringing the Justice League to the big
screen to be a thank you you put it
better than I ever did
like I'm I've softened to the point
where I'm like hey man if I just have a
good time watching this and I feel yeah
positive when I leave the room I'll be
happy I guess I don't really get the
impression this is gonna be a very
moving picture I don't either it looks
like it's real it looks like it's just a
big visual feast with a lot of action
and a lot of humor and just you're just
going there to have a fun time that's
all it really looks like to me yeah it
looks exactly like a hybrid between a
Zack Snyder meets a Joss Whedon done
yeah and it feels like somebody sewed
the two together yeah I haven't been
worried about Justice League I really
haven't all I've been I've been hopeful
that it's good and I've been thinking
like I'm probably just gonna be really
entertained cuz last thing I wanted to
bored that's that's what BBS went wrong
with me is that I found it dull and
boring if it was just you know
entertaining I would have been much
happier about life yeah it's kind of
long and really self serious and I'm
glad this isn't doing that so it just
kind of gives me a saving grace however
I did here and I don't know if Warner
Brothers just doing this to be safe or
they don't have confidence in it I did
hear that there will not be a reviews
released on this movie on that famous
Rotten Tomatoes capsule that the DC EU
has a very healthy relationship with
released until the day before the movie
on average when that happens that means
a movie sucks they want everyone to buy
their advance tickets before they can
all read a review about it yeah I have a
hard time seeing how this can go
completely wrong I just can go right
flashy got Batman you got Supes showing
up eventually in support of this movie
you know Wonder Woman in there and you
even got a cyborg who everyone knows
they've really done a great job injury
yeah you're gonna go to that mascara
you're gonna go to Atlantis you're gonna
go everywhere in the world I'm like how
can it is not just at least be an
amusing entertaining film have a very
hard time wrapping my head around that
this is gonna be boring ya know I feel
you cuz I there's something i find a bit
strange about the fact that every
character just looks like they kind of
feel like this is awesome
but at the same time that's kind of
weird enough that i might enjoy watching
that yeah and the marketing is really
promoting the team aspect to it which
which I appreciate because you have to
yeah I just wish they would give us some
scenes because the thing is I don't I
don't either so editing them but see the
thing is while they're selling me this
movie it's like I know they're all gonna
get together and they're all gonna fight
in the same room but the thing none of
these trailers have given me is their
chemistry I don't feel chemistry between
anybody because I haven't seen anybody
really react in any of these
I want Batman to fight one of them you
know how like there's a hope versus the
world I want Batman to fight one other
person on the Justice League and just
get his ass already following you yeah
super baby I don't want to dip into the
other jar but like part of the reason
why the Avengers worked and like it
takes an incredible amount of four of
foresight is they all have chemistry
when they get together and when they're
separate I know there are certain people
that we care about in this Justice
League and there are certain people that
we haven't gotten to know yet that's
something that I am really shaky on
going into this movie I understand none
of these trailers have cleared up I
understand it seems like just crisis
surrounds this movie what John they like
finish post-production like a month ago
when we finish a video even if it's a
sketch you know finished I turned in
most all my homework right after finish
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell please because you
won't get notified unless you click the
bell dad Sean Humphrey is my name and he
is the Greg album on urine always check
us out on patreon patreon comm slash the
real rejects become a patron ejected a
keep a look up or our Justice League
review Cinemark know ho will be there
product placement for Cinemark I hope
you pay us